ja was eigentlich heute bewegt mich hat
eigentlich etwas bewegt gar nicht
unbedingt aufgeregt aber mich hat bewegt
oder erfüllt mit sorge
gerade am vorabend des großen klima
streiks denen wir morgen in deutschland
sehen in kreta thunberg ist bereits
angesprochen kommt auch nach deutschland
also dieser klima streik soll ja noch
mal darauf hinwirken noch schneller
beispielsweise aus der kohlekraft
auszusteigen des heers das ziel 20 38
und wenn wir uns mal anschauen dass auch
deutschland schon 20 22 also in den
nächsten jahres die letzten drei
kernkraftwerke abschaltet idealerweise
fordern die grünen den kohleausstieg um
acht jahre vorzieht auf 20 30 und feines
verfügt aber ja am liebsten auch sofort
raus aus der kohle da muss man sich
schon einmal die frage stellen wie soll
das eigentlich alles in deutschland hier
funktionieren ich mache mir angst um die
stromversorgung denn das größte problem
wäre deutschland steigt aus der
kernkraft und der kohle aus und muss
dann ganz ganz viel strom importieren
beispielsweise
atomstrom aus frankreich oder noch viel
schlimmer den großen kohlestrom aus
polen beispielsweise oder tschechien
also was bedeutet das ich glaube wer
klimaschutz ernst nehmen will und
wirklich betreiben möchte der muss
wieder in die kernkraft einsteigen wir
sehen es ja weltweit sind über 100
meiler im bau
kernkraft ist und wir reden jetzt nicht
mehr über den stand von 186 tschernobyl
eine technologie die von vielen vielen
ländern beherrscht wird und wenn andere
länder das beherrschen warum soll
eigentlich deutschland diese technologie
nicht beherrschen ist für mich
unverständlich bei wachsenden
energiehunger dass deutschland sich
wirklich einer sehr sauberen ich sage
extra sauberen technologie beruf beraubt
ja tatsächlich ich habe also na ja also
im grunde genommen ich hatte kurzzeitig
ergeben sich im wahlkampf
und an eine zustimmung schon ein
bisschen problematisch ist aber im kern
würde ich dem zustimmen also ich glaube
dass der ausstieg
seinerzeit
zwar richtig war aufgrund der vorkommen
dass in fukushima aber rückblickend
vielleicht
anders herum hätte folgen sollen und
aber müssen die frage ist ja was
passiert wenn wir die kohle vorziehen
was ja sogar was wo man ja sogar sagen
könnte aus co2 gründen mag das sinnvoll
seien es am ende glaube ich ist egal ob
die deutschen aus der kohle aufsteiger
nicht es werden weltweit über 400 neue
kohlekraftwerke gebaut zur zeit also
dass man da hingestellt aber wenn wir
sagen wir steigen früher aus der kohle
aus dann muss dieses gap dieses loch
größe geführt werden und müsste man so
ehrlich sein zu sagen dass man wieder
mehr atomanlagen ersten halbjahr hatten
wir 40 prozent strom anteil kohle und
kernkraft 40 prozent deutschland ja
vorstellen fast die hälfte kam aus
diesen beiden energieträgern aus denen
wir raus sollen wenn es nach zweites
verfügt er geht oder auch den grünen in
neun jahren also rückkehr so gern ich
rechne mir bin waren elf prozent
atomenergie davon fand ich mich jetzt
prozent ich glaube
wir reden ja über wir ihn über beides
jaja er aber jetzt du hast kernenergie
atomenergie angesprochen ich glaube es
ist politisch kaum durchsetzbar dass wir
jetzt wieder die kraftwerke ausbauen
oder wieder öffnen wir haben kein
endlager
darum muss man sich auch kümmern wir
können nicht einfach die atomenergie
wieder sagen hier jetzt mehr aber wir
haben kein endlager wo wirst dann
bringen die keine ahnung von ok und zum
probieren das ist alles was ich
überlegen die speicherdauer das ist
ungenau die entwickeln wir die
entwickeln wir noch laufen ja weniger
bürokratie was wind und solarenergie
angeht und dann müssen es schaffen
technologien eigentlich an den start
aber solange wir sagen der problem
solange wir sie nicht haben es gibt
jetzt schon tage an denen deutschland
atomstrom aus frankreich sortiert oder
beispielsweise kohlestrom aus polen wir
reden immer das sind wir seit jahren und
sind von den grünen wir brauchen
speichern speicher in speyer ist doch
richtig wir haben sie zurzeit noch nicht
was machen wir mit 40 prozent strom
anteil wenn der nicht mehr da ist wie
gleichen wir den aus ja das ist eine
sehr unangenehme diskussion muss man
ganz klar sagen zwei tage vor der wahl
würde ich diese diskussion hätte ich
ehrlich gesagt sie haben ja schon gesagt
ja aber ich glaube da wird einfach auch
zur wahrheit dazu dass entweder wird man
sich die kerne
dass sie im wahlkampf offen das wollen
wir doch alle doch da habe ich auch
keine persönlichkeit stress mit ich ob
das klug ist etwas anderes
aber ich glaube schon dass man mit der
kernenergie in irgendeiner form wird
sich anfreunden ist das ist nicht nur
tag so sei es ist ja ist ja wieder
spannend immer wenn wir das
ist ja doch ganz spannend weil eine
sache lieber jan bei dir auch die wird
immer vergessen es gab nämlich mal einen
atomkonsens und wir hätten diese
probleme die wir jetzt haben gar nicht
mit den frage wo holen wir die
alternativen energien er wenn wir diesen
atomkonsens aus dem jahr 2000 die
aufgekündigt hätten den gab es nämlich
mit vier großen
kraftwerksbetreibern gab es eine
laufzeit regelung wie lange die
atomkraftwerke laufen und im konsens im
übrigen da hat man sich mit denen einen
tisch gesetzt und gesagt okay ich
schwierig für euch aber wir machen das
jetzt die rot grüne bundesregierung
damals gemacht paar jahre ist es her und
dann kam die regierung
das war dann
schwarz gelb genau die dann gesagt hat
nein schluss damit unterstützt von einer
riesigen anzeigenkampagne wir kündigen
diesen atomkonsens jetzt auf und wir
machen eine laufzeitverlängerung
garantieren also den betreibern den
kraftwerksbetreibern ihr kriegt mehr
längere laufzeit und könnt eure
kraftwerk auch länger nutzen das war
2010 ähnlich
das später einmal ein jahr später wir
haben 30 06 2011 hat der bundestag
entschieden auf einmal nein wir machen
eine rückwärtsrolle von der
rückwärtsrolle und sagen atomkraft ist
ja des teufels das wird bis heute
aber als der ausstieg aus der atomkraft
ausstieg hat eigentlich schon im jahre
2000 ist ändert das problem nicht viel
doch wir wären viel weiter wenn es nicht
die rückrunde der rückrunde gekümmert
und jetzt deswegen reagiere ich ein so
sehen wir eine eine meinungsbildung ich
sage das sehr neutral wo dann mitglieder
des zukunftsteams von armin laschet
sagen ja das ist etwas was ich mir
durchaus vorstellen aber hatten
minister will
aber
weltweit werden 100 über 100 neue meiler
auch gebaut das heißt ich glaube nicht
gemacht ist ja aber der punkt ist ja
weil du jetzt gerade so darstellt wenn
man den den atomausstieg von 2000
konsequent fortgeführt hätte da hätten
wir jetzt speichertechnologie wenn die
andere länder hätten dann würden sie
auch keine kernkraft gebaut diese
speichertechnologie gibt es weltweit
noch nicht so verfügbar ich glaube da
ist der deutsche atomausstieg der dann
um zwei jahre verlängert wurde nicht das
zünglein an der waage gewesen der macht
es also die die speichertechnologie ist
nicht da und jetzt stellen wir fest wir
wollen uns 40 prozent der
stromproduktion rausnehmen brauchen aber
bis 20 30 nach berechnungen 25 prozent
mehr strom als wir heute brauchen wir ja
auch wenn man mit dem auto war in frage
war also angekommen aber genau weniger
produktion bei mehrbedarf bei
7.000 km leitungen die wir bauen müssen
irgendwie schon seit zehn jahren bisher
gebaut 1500 kilometer leitung um von
offshore dann auf short parks aus der
nordseewind auch in den süden oder
windenergie engine zu bekommen deswegen
müssen plan und war ganz unten aber ich
vorhin sagten zukunftsteam das thema
liegt hier bei man die jung und jage
winter also dass auch hier aber das
waren alles persönliche meinung dass
während der reden jetzt um den banken
bereicherung koran bei anderen dingen so
klar glaube ich hier drückt sich jeder
auch das war doch klar dass ich da meine
meinung gesagt stehen und übergreifend
privatmeinung also der pegel an die
jungen und siege winter hierhin
bestellen sie können der referate
früheren war schon hier
nochmal rein da kann sie das nämlich
noch in einem referat einmal darlegen
also das ist eine privatmeinung aber
mich würde interessieren was du dazu
sagen weil ihr könnt die fragestellung
war da
ich habe eine riesige rassam nie sagen
wir haben keine wir haben keinen kein
endlager wir haben keine möglichkeit
atommüll
momente für die wir waren ja bei einer
atomkraft dass wir da eine kleine lücke
da kommen wir gleich hin wir haben keine
möglichkeit deswegen schaltet die
atomkraft für mich aus zu tun als wäre
es auf einmal eine sichere technologie
wo die atomkraftwerke nicht mehr sind
wie tschernobyl ist ja okay kann ja
alles sein trotzdem hat keiner eine
lösung was mit dem atommüll
irgendwie kann auch nicht vergraben
werden was drauf tut es gerne mal
mehrere gekippt nein einer das so aber
ist nun das zweite ist dass es wie ich
da nicht ausreicht dass es sie diese
lücke gibt ich bin dabei man kann nicht
wie peter altmaier gesagt hat einfach
den strom unter regel und sagen du
letzten vier ist das übrigens
gegraben es ist eine schlucht der graf
40 prozesse sehr schlottmann eine
übergangstechnologie und es gibt viele
viele interessante ideen es gibt gut es
gibt zum beispiel gas es gibt
wasserstoff da gibt es auch diese
diskussion muss es grüner wasserstoff
sein also wasserstoff aus nur
erneuerbaren energien oder darf es auch
blauer wasserstoff sein also aus
herkömmlichen gas ich bin dafür dass man
diese technologie nutzt aber solange es
keine lösung gibt was mit dem atommüll
wird bin ich dafür keine atomkraft zu
nutzen aber das bedeutet wir lassen den
dreckigen kohlestrom weiter nach
deutschland wir versorgen uns mit
atomstrom aus frankreich beispielsweise
nicht dann haben wir ein sauberes
gewissen wunderbare
ordinationen wie die usa china müssten
doch massiv auf setzt die holländer
überlegen
wohin zwei neue bauen das genauso wie
man hier kohlekraftwerke schließen und
pakistan machen neue auch das ist auch
näher und wir ja genau der der regierung
geführt von angela merkel ist im letzten
jahr eingeführt worden in diesem jahr im
letzten jahr eingeführt worden ein
wasserstoff bad nauheim grund damit
beschäftigt man sich zum ausbau dieser
wirtschaft das ist gut diese ev ist kann
man nutzen stärker muss ich sagen alle
ölheizungen müssen abgeschaltet werden
es gibt da alternative technologien
hasst man muss weniger rigoros werden
und die technologischen möglichkeiten
was wäre denn nur als vorschlag wenn wir
die technologien alle entwickeln das
sind ja auch sehr vielversprechenden
technologien und wir steigen dann aus
wenn wir sie entwickelt haben jetzt gibt
es besteht ja eine riesen problem für
den für die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft
der welt
deutschland dass es diese diese
dramatische energie schlucht gibt so und
so lange wir das nicht lösen sagt was
alles fast alles gute technologien gibt
und wo man was machen kann und hier und
da aber de facto haben wir bis jetzt
gibt es keinen plan diese lücke zu
schließen dass das sehe ich wie du die
freie liste futures sagen und da haben
sie ein bisschen einer domains sagen
dass sagt wir uns ewig schon aber er tut
es ja doch nicht wollen wir nochmal
bewegen man muss nur genug weil ja
was heißt das
also macht sich und macht ist
freundlichkeit es wird schon ewig gesagt
ja das gibt es ganz so stimmt ja was du
sagst aber es wird nicht umgesetzt und
ich finde da muss mehr passieren da muss
bürokratie weniger werden damit man die
flächen die man hat für solar- und
windenergie zum beispiel damit man die
nutzen kann auch also wir machen die
natur kaputten war ganz kurz zu machen
die natur kaputt enke ist ein riesiger
also wir holzen bäumer passiert ja alles
in wäldern reinhardswald beispielsweise
in hessen werden bäume abgeholzt die ja
eigentlich nachwachsender rohstoffe sind
andere bundesländer schleswig holstein
wollen ja mehr bauen bestand die pfosten
auf aber in anderen bundesländer wird
abgeholzt um
windkraftanlagen zu bauen um als
beispiel kann man ja machen man muss
immer bloß sagen wenn ich für bäume auf
die straße gehe keine sagen aber sind
die ab heute in hamm besitz ich damit
kein baum gerodet wird im reinhardt 2
reinhardt zwar in hessen sitzt keiner da
werden sollen der wird gerodet um
windkraftanlagen aufzubauen das passt
nicht zusammen das ist dass es wirklich
an an doppelmoral nicht zu überbieten
und nochmal das ist jetzt langweilig für
die zuschauer ich mich über wiederhole
wir haben das problem nicht gelöst ja
dann aber das heißt wenn man sich damit
abfinden muss mir die sagen dann fahren
wir jetzt schon mal zu üben am tag nur
noch drei stunden nicht an aber das ist
ja genau das also man hat ja keine
lösung das ist ja immer nur verzichten
und deswegen wir mal sehen was er noch
in zukunft ist andere länder lachen sich
kaputt sie fangen angelpunkt wir sehen
das problem deutschland hat einen
energien droht eine resolution ehrlich
wir machen mehr kraftwerke und verkaufen
dann auch noch unseren strom schön teuer
nach deutschland da freut sich jeder
junge mensch jeder rentner nach holt
sich jeder über teuren strom das noch zu
unheilig noch einfach in china eröffnet
jede woche ein kraftwerk das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen und das weltklima müssen
wir ein globales und deswegen fand ich
diesen einwand es ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich keiner von uns sagt
holtze lösung lässt uns verrückt sondern
natürlich dass mit der und herrlichkeit
lassen nicht ganz wichtig ich glaube da
konntest du einmal auf frankreich
eingehen und den punkt den fand ich eben
ein bisschen untergegangen hier aber wir
werden ja beziehen können wir die
wahrheit das ist ja so viel werden strom
irgendwoher beziehen wenn wir sagen
angeschaltet unsere kernkraftwerke
bleiben aus dann kommt der strom
trotzdem irgendwo her und das ist glaube
ich so ein bisschen berg den wir jetzt
gerade haben in der moral aber
china baut hat bekannt gegeben ja gerade
kein neues kohlekraftwerk mehr außerhalb
von china was sie ja in den letzten
jahren massiv gemacht haben ich glaube
auch diese entscheidung es ist
sicherlich ein teil des druckes der
allgemein entfacht worden ist und aber
ist laut über 40 kernkraftwerken das
stimmt auch beide fakten sind richtig
mein fakt war auch richtig alle fakten
und ja ich aber natürlich ist das auch
ein einwand das stand ja also da gibt es
schon positive effekte was das angeht
durch den druck der fachte entfacht wird
auch auf der straße der ja auch in der
börse mittlerweile eine große rolle
spielt weil selbst solche großen
institutionellen anleger wie blackrock
oder sagen wir investieren nicht mal in
fossile energien und dergleichen und
leute die keinen klimaneutralen ansatz
fahren also da passiert gerade
wahnsinnig viel wir sind
unterschiedlicher meinung bei der
atomkraft aber ansonsten braucht ist
eine brückentechnologie bis man in die
neue technologie einsteigen kann
[Musik]